ladies and gentlemen thank you for
listening to another episode of River
with Griffin and as usual we are looking
for the perfect theme song for rifra
Griffin so if you have some ideas out
there I need you to send a minute let me
know but for now every podcast you
listen to every move you make every bond
you break every time you shake I'll be
watching you every single day every
podcast you say every game you play
every night you stay up watching you
with in with Griffin
I I crack myself up I don't know I need
a theme song so until I come up with one
I'm just gonna keep doing that
anyways guys thanks for listening to
rhythm with Griffin this is another
episode now
the episode numbers have been kind of
weird that's on me cuz what happened was
I did a live episode and I just did it
on Twitter periscope but I never put it
on my channel so that was really episode
two so now this is episode three even
the last time I said episode three two
or three so let's just officially make
this episode three even though I'm gonna
have it marked on I don't know whatever
who cares right what am I even saying
but anyways thanks for listening to me
once again I'm back and why always
coffee I was called from my damn pocket
um today I want to discuss some dating
shows that I've been watching and it's
just craziness like why is this such an
obsession that we have like I was
watching I was watching like 90 day
fiancé that's the one man 90 day fiancé
- it is is ill man that is that is such
a ill show you know like I don't get I
just don't get why people do this like
what is I think you know these TV shows
they exploit people's need for love like
they people search like people are
always searching for love and they can't
find it in conventional places like
people don't go to bars people don't go
to clubs anymore we're not really
interacting with people right we don't
interact like you know where we go out
someplace that we see someone we go hey
how you doing and we spark up a
conversation we have to do it online
I'm not completely against meeting
people online I mean I think that it's a
safe space you know imagine if you went
up to a bar in a bar and you had and you
could ask somebody hey can I see your
dossier and they had like a little file
and they were like hey here here's my
file then you could look through their
file and be like okay I see you like a
bunch of pictures this is nice I see
where you went to school I see you know
who's to say that this is true but it
just gives you a little bit of like a
little insight into somebody as opposed
to just like some random stranger and
then what do you do you end up having to
get their number anyway and you have to
call them and talk to them and try to
get to know them so just like Facebook
and things like that are kind of like a
fast-track it's like oh well here's let
me go ahead and jump ahead in like you
know going through that like stead that
awkward get to know phase or to that
little phase right before get to know is
like do I want to get to know enough
that I want to get to know you well
that's what that is but like a lot of
these reality shows are just all about
this you know they're just exploiting
people like catfish I don't understand
how catfish is in its seventh season 7
seasons people are still letting this
happen like this is a big thing this is
what everybody's you know listen season
one you didn't watch season why getting
cuz its season 1 season 2 you didn't
watch season 1 but season 3 I'm like go
[ __ ] yourself at that point like you
don't know what the hell is going on at
this point
so was crazy and that show was ill you
know it's like it always is the same
thing like 60 70 percent of the time
it's a fat girl you know and don't get
mad at me this is the show ok he's like
it's some fat girl that's the first part
and then she's like you don't see her
yet you know but a lot of times it's a
fat girl lying to some guy and she's
using a picture of some hot girl and
they've been in a relationship for like
a year and he's finally going I really
want to meet her but I'm feeling
suspicious after a year he's feeling
suspicious like you haven't really seen
her every time you make plans Oh
something falls through and you're in
this really deep meaningful relationship
for a year it's like get out of here I
don't get I just I just don't get it I
mean I get it actually I mean I've
experienced being catfished
my damn self but I'm just saying I at
that time the internet was new and fresh
and you had no you didn't you had no
recourse there was no that your phones
didn't even have cameras at the time you
know it was like it was like weird time
that was like prime catfishing time was
in the beginning but now everything's
good you got hang time FaceTime Google
Chat you know there's so many things
that apps that you're on that come with
a video thing it's like get on there you
should only get catfished for like 13
minutes but anyways so and then the guy
wants to meet her and this is the part
that pisses me off I don't even care
that the girl's lying like it's messed
up you think did you go all man this fat
girl or even fat guy whoever lying you
know
this lying right but by the way it's
either a fat girl who's lying to a dude
or it's a fat girl who thinks she's
talking to a really hot in shape guy
either way
it's a fat girl and the fat girl who
thinks she's talking to an in shape guy
oftentimes it ends up being a fat girl
it's crazy
that's like 60% at a time it's like some
one of those scenarios and of course
obviously there's always a like some fat
guy who thinks he's talking to some you
know super hot model you know it's like
what are you doing bro like really you
haven't seen her like anyways but does
the part it pisses me off the dude
talking to the girl he'll always say
this to Lev and Max when he meets them
he'll be like he's like yeah I need to
meet her cuz this is the most profound
relationship I've been in in my life I
am Who I am today because of this person
and then he meets the fat girl and it's
usually like in a park or something like
that and he's like what who is that and
I'm like hey dude what happened to the
most profound relationship in your life
you shallow piece of [ __ ] like then
don't say all that stuff just say all
you care about is what this person looks
like but that's gonna be a whole other
episode about people being shallow I
have a lot to say about that
we're all shallow I'm sure we're all
it's just like how you deal with it is
who you are but anyways
and that's catfish something there's a
bunch of shows like this like and then
now there's these shows where people get
married on the show or they're looking
for love and this is the thing that
infuriates me like there was a show
spouse house where you have to get
married in the house you just met these
people
and people are surprised that this [ __ ]
doesn't work like regular marriage
doesn't work people who are have been
dating for years that they get together
in a conventional way 50% of those
marriages don't work and you expect in
this to work like what I just I don't
get it
y'all I don't get it so spouse house was
a crazy one that was on I think that one
was on TLC too but that was like you go
and I always look like you wait six
seven months later and you look like are
they still together and of course most
of them aren't together I mean oh the
irony of it is there are people like
when when this show was dedicated
towards like the bachelor or
bachelorette they're trying to get
married those things don't work out but
these other reality shows like say Big
Brother for instance a lot of people get
married after meeting each other on Big
Brother because they went through that
experience together and then they start
dating afterwards and then they go on
for a year or something then they come
back and be like oh wow you know they
got married but the intention wasn't to
go on and get married for some reason
the intention to go on and get married
on these other shows it turns people
crazy I mean it's insane
so 90-day fiance is one of those now the
reason why it's called 90-day fiance is
because if you're traveling abroad or
somebody is here in the United States
you have 90 days while you for a
vacation and then you have to move back
so or unless you get a work visa or you
get married and so that's what the
premise of this show is it's these
couples that and then there's I have my
notes this time to there's three kinds
of couples there are three kinds of
couples on 90 day fiancé that that just
infuriate me okay so the one called
is like the hot like the the attractive
couple it's like a couple that like
somebody was on vacation you know and
they went on vacation or they were on a
mission but there's a lot of Mormon
missions on the show so they go on
vacation and then they meet somebody who
they are genuinely attracted to just
right off looks and they go I'm
attracted to this person and then they
decide hey they had this quick romance
oh then obviously they'll a they hit up
the show and then the shows like all you
guys are perfect for this and now
they're in the show and they're in the
show process and these couples are like
you know they seem you would think okay
that's the one that's gonna work and
that's because we're so shallow minded
we're so shallow thing is I will that
they're both attractive so that means
you should work out like like as if
personality and all that kind of stuff
doesn't even matter but that's one
couple that's on that show not add a
fiancee then you have the online dating
couples and this is usually like
sometimes they're both attractive people
but a lot of times it's like I'm like a
difference in like you know maybe
somebody's super old or somebody's super
fat or somebody's super four and they're
super young and that's that online
dating thing right and then uh then and
then usually the other couple that you
see a lot of them are is exactly what
I'm saying it's like I don't know why
it's like a really fat somebody is super
fat not a shape and they're they think
they're in love with some in shape
foreign person and they're and initially
you feel like that person is just trying
to get their visa even though in the hot
couple that couple they also you would
think one of them is just trying to get
the visa too but for some reason we're
more okay with that when you look at it
you don't get as angry wing but when you
see this fat person who is spending all
their money and changing their life and
and in and making their family just feel
uncomfortable and and worried about them
for some reason because the person is
fat we feel so much more for them you
just get you feel sorry for them and
it's such a it sucks you know but that's
the thing and so there's some couples on
this show they absolutely infuriate me
you know if 90-day fiance happily ever
after if you get to this but it's all
the same they're all like they all start
the same it starts like before the 90
days after the 90 days what's going on
with them now
but there's a few couples that I want to
talk about you should watch the show
it's a very bizarre show it will make
you it's a psychological experiment on
like like how people get when people get
together and you start to see the things
that you should do in your relationships
before you just get into a relationship
I'm telling you that right now like one
of the couples Russ and Paola they're
one of my favorite couples rusts from
Oklahoma he's a dude from Oklahoma so he
was traveling to Colombia and he met
Paola and she's this beautiful busty
Colombian woman fiery and you know busty
mean unless she got big old titties and
they had this like romance you know and
he's like I I really want to be with you
and then they have this whirlwind
romance it's the whole 90 day thing and
he obviously they hit up the show and
then she moves to Oklahoma with him and
so but she's from Colombia and he's this
sort of down-home
not a country type guy but he's like
strict he's very conservative and she is
this busty like she wants to wear
Legolas
you know skimpy stuff and she wants to
be a model right and so they're in
Oklahoma and they're not happy she's
crying every day she misses her family
and then you know they decide to move to
Miami you know he was like he worked on
like an oil rig or something like that
we had a great job making a lot of money
and he gave that up for her and they
moved to Miami so she could be a model
now listen I'm dating a model I'm
talking about a real model like a model
a sense of like fashion model it's
different types of models but when
people say model you always think of
like you know even if you think
Victoria's Secret they have a certain
look they're not supposed to like
they're not to me like like a fashion
model it's not supposed to distract you
from the fashion that they're wearing
they're supposed to blend it's supposed
to be a perfect mix and then you like
this weird fashion they have on it's not
gonna be you're not gonna be distracted
by like you know huge breasts and a big
oh ass so whatever whatever it is like
that I think it just works like that
listed is it's closer design that way
but pie Lola wants to be a model and I'm
not sure what kind of model she wants to
be but for some reason
all the modeling that she does is sort
of like you know a little x-rated a
little like it's very sexual and stuff
and the conservative rust has a problem
with that so then that's the first thing
right there that's where they always are
clashing and sometimes I'm with her
sometimes I'm like hey yo you need to
like chill out and just let let her do
her thing you should have to trust her
then the other times I'm thinking to
myself well hey he already made it very
clear like he won't he'll say something
like please don't wear lingerie at this
shoot and then the next thing you know
she got the lingerie on so that's like
their communication issue right there
but overall they seem to be a okay
couple but what happens with them is
their families her family in particular
she was in Colombia she was a big part
of the family and as she moved as she
stopped keeping in contact and the
family blamed him and then she's got
this gay best friend and this dude and
the husband and Russ are always fighting
they're just fighting all the time and I
feel like when you're getting into a
relationship you have to meet that
person's family they have to meet your
family and for the most part you would
like them to get along meet the friends
meet because they don't that's gonna be
a problem
it's gonna be a problem and it's gonna
be especially for you if you're the
person that's in the middle of your
friend and the person you're trying to
be with believe me that [ __ ] is a
nightmare you know
because you want them to get along they
don't even realize how much they have in
common that's the real rub because
obviously you you like of course you
like different types of people but the
people that are the closest to you like
your best friend and a girl or man that
you are in love with I bet you that your
best friend in that person they have a
little bit in common there's something
that there's a common ground there and
when they don't get along you're just
like oh man
and it's usually for dumb reasons
jealousy and insecurities and dumb [ __ ]
like that but you see it on this show so
it's like an experiment while you're
looking at these people and you're like
what how are you guys together with
without dealing with all these issues
and it's just like but that's a couple I
believe they're still together that
worked out
look at me I'm going through all the car
I got to go through these couples
Chantell and pedro oh my god I hate all
of these I hate both of them and their
families this is an example of what I'm
talking about this is another hot couple
this is another she's on vacation she
meets this guy and then they have like a
whirlwind romance and they decide they
want to get married they can't obviously
they contacted the show someplace in
there and now they are they are trying
to you know make this happen right so
he's in Dominican Republic he's
Dominican okay and then her she's from
like I forgot where she's from but then
her family is the worst all right they
hate him they are always accusing him of
trying to use her they are out there
there they make it uncomfortable and her
younger brother is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
every single time she they they were the
mom and dad are crazy they had these
like weird ideas about him oh they won't
they won't get passed they get in their
own way and then his family Pedro's
family his mom and sister are nightmares
you know he wants to send money home cuz
he says it's cultural he wants to keep
sending money home to take care he's the
man of the house and he wants to take
care of his mom and his sister and they
live in this three-bedroom place
three-bedroom two-bath and then in the
States
he's living in a one-bedroom with his
wife and so she has this idea like
you're taking care of them but you're
not taking care of me even though the
cost of living is probably way cheaper
in the Dominican Republic so it's not
the same thing they're just not
communicating properly together they're
not really getting together and talking
about the issue like how can you know
it's just a lack of communication
because they don't know each other that
well but anyway the mom and sister
they're impossible you know that the
family the woman
chantell's family goes over and then the
mom tries to feed them chicken feet
chicken feet I think the more and in
America mom is all like you know you
think we're dumb Americans and you know
this is insulting and so then it's just
constant bickering and fighting over and
over again and I thought about it is
get together meet everybody's family and
see how you feel about it these families
are never gonna get along and even if
these people claim to love each other if
they grow to love each other through the
adversity that they created themselves I
mean damn you still have this
uncomfortable environment with these
ignorant ass people because they
ignorant the both families ignorant as a
[ __ ] okay I can't stand them got
addy fiance one step now you have George
and Anna fisa and this is one of the fat
ones George is the kind of fat you know
he's a dumpy guy
I got can relate and he meets some
Russian girl online
she's beautiful young you know beautiful
body and he tells her I'm gonna take
care of you I'm gonna I'm gonna shower
you with gifts and all this and she's
like cool I'm gonna come move she gets
here and he's been lying the dudes
middle life he don't got that kind of
money and then it's just this once again
it's like why would you make that choice
you mean you came over here like on
prompt like well if you're a whole
reason by coming over here is because
you think the dudes gonna take care of
you like that's a stupid reason right
there you get everything you deserve but
at the same time she is here and now
she's by herself she don't got our visa
she got to get married his sister hates
her calls her a [ __ ] and all this stuff
and it's like you know it's like this is
another example of like this was not a
good decision and you and I always asked
would she be with a guy like that if
they had met at a bar in Russia you know
she's Russian
you know maybe who knows but like I
think they would have had a better
chance to like hey let's get to know
each other but he's you know what George
still would have lied hit me he's a liar
and he played a game he lied right on
the show he he's like like she's gonna
be able to watch what really happened
you know he lied about going to a no
divorce attorney and then when they got
back together after he messed up you
know he was on the one of those wrap-up
shows talking about you know ask her
what she does ask her what she does for
a living you know he's trying to claim
that she was like an online prostitute
or something like that even though she
would that's how he met her she was on
on webcams but anyway so that couple so
that's a couple of you go like you know
you gotta watch they they are always
fighting and she's fiery and she's like
hitting him for no reason which is
another crazy double standard like a
woman can hit you for no [ __ ] reason
at all I'm talking about if she feels it
she could just haul off and slap you in
the face and then we just go okay that's
how that you know she's fiery you gotta
be careful with that one but I mean you
imagine if he would have been like what
did you say and just smacked her it's
like a whole thing you know but she's
very volatile like he should call the
cops on her that's what I feel but
that's a volatile couple you know and
then you got this oh I remember this one
Daniella and Mohammad again she's this
big fat older woman and she's meeting up
with this Muslim this Muslim guy who's
trying to get out of the country that
he's in he's super in shape and and then
they just they just don't look like a
mix there's never any affection or
anything like that and it just turns
into a mess and you're just like why did
they get together the first place why
would you put yourself through this
there's so many of these couples Molly
and Luis was another one she's
40-something years old he's 26 and then
like you know he's this young fiery he
just wants to get to the it you get the
impression that he just wants to get to
the United States get his visa and go
move on with his life you know and she
thinks oh this like I'm in love he's the
one for me [ __ ] I don't I don't don't
even get me don't even get me started
now the one that really the reason why I
even made the podcast about this is this
couple Nicole and Azen this sweet fat
girl from like North Carolina she's just
you know big and chubby but cute as hell
she got a cute face and she just she
just wants to love she's got a little
girl and she meets this guy and in
Morocco you know I mean they're in
Morocco and she's all like you know oh
he's the one and then she's sending him
money all the time and then she's
talking to him on the phone all the time
and he can't get his visa because he
might have some criminal record and then
she decides she wants to move to Morocco
and marry him
there and she like uproots her life
leaves her leaves her family takes her
young daughter who now has to go to
school in Morocco and then she thinks
he's cheating on on her and you know
it's like there's no common sense at all
in any of this it's like go visit him oh
and that's another thing too she goes
and visits him right like they're not a
match you don't really stop they go on a
hike
she is suffering on this hike cuz she's
a big fat girl she don't work out
suffering he's trying to pull her up the
hill he's all telling her baby maybe you
should you know you know you should get
in shape and then she's like I told you
I don't work out does that sound like a
match to you does this sound like a
match but it makes for great TV and
that's what I cannot stand I think it's
exploitative that's even a word they're
exploiting people's stupidity you know
it's just man I don't know why do we do
this you know why do we do it why do we
search for love in all the wrong places
I don't know like I actually met my
girlfriend on online but I made sure
right away I was like come to my show
it's so like I said I don't think
there's anything wrong with meeting
somebody online make that the initial
thing that's the the introduction the
hey how you doing like your pictures
chat a little bit but then immediately
get off of that give him your number get
their number make plans go do something
go sit down for coffee sit across from a
person and really talk to him look in
their eyes do you know how different it
is like I don't care how close or
romantic you think you are if you're
just texting that is not real
communication you lose the nuance of of
what somebody is saying their body
language you're not as brave you have to
like actually be thoughtful and think
about what you're saying before you say
things to people but this is how we're
communicating now this is what we're
doing everybody's chatting and talking
online and talking through snapchat and
Twitter and Instagram and
that's not real communication get off
those [ __ ] devices and look people in
the eye interact with them that this is
get out there and do that please it's so
frustrating I don't know and I wish to
these shows I'm at you know it's like I
wish these shows would stop taking
advantage of like just how naive and
dumb people can be you know I was
looking up on the Internet today and I
see a lot of the 90-day fiance couples
are together but the ones that are
together I think they're the ones that
they had like a more organic
relationship from the start it was like
it wasn't some super old guy with a
super young girl it wasn't like you know
it wasn't like some big fat guy a big
fat guy a big fat girl that they met
online there's this other couple to this
big fat guy and he don't have any money
and he moved the girl from Thailand and
now she wants to have kids and he don't
we have money and he's living in a
firehouse he got his his son got shot
and then he don't have any money it's
like that was a kind of that's not gonna
work but interact with people in real
life in real time I'm telling you it's
worth it it really is I know we feel
like it's an inconvenience we feel like
it's like we don't owe me I don't want
to be that vulnerable till I talk to
somebody I don't know why in modern
society now young people think it's
uncomfortable to talk on the phone but
you're screaming for it that's why you
have emojis and all this stuff that's
you trying your best to like be more
real just be real you know even start
with FaceTime FaceTime look at somebody
let them look at you really interact I'm
telling you it's totally completely
gonna change your experience haven't you
ever talked to somebody on the phone and
then you met them in / even when you
talk to someone on the phone and you
meet them in person you're like ooh
something's weird here this is a little
off it always happens like that
you mean online you're like oh this is
cool and then you
uh you know you talked to him you know
on the phone and you're like oh that was
different maybe you like him then you
meet him in person and then they have
some little nuance or quark that is not
coming through through the text message
it's not coming through on the phone
call it's not coming through when you
look at them in the eye and you actually
talk to them so I mean that's the
essence of all this right now is like
those shows frustrate the [ __ ] out of me
and the way we're communicating right
now in society is frustrating as hell so
I'm just that's my message to everybody
right now get out there and actually
connect please connect Connect connect
connect connect all right that's the
main part of riffing with Griffin but
what I'm gonna start doing is I'm gonna
have segments I wanna you know after
this you know so one of my segments is
gonna be like I also want to talk about
I saw a couple of great movies well they
weren't that great
I mean Halloween just passed and I saw
the nun I was really disappointed in the
nun and then I saw Halloween the new
Halloween and it was like it wasn't bad
Jamie Lee Curtis is still a bad
[ __ ] you know still Michaels
still trying to get her you know it's
like a very entertaining movie
you're not gonna hate it in it ends but
you still don't know is this
[ __ ] still alive I don't know
how many times he gonna get burned and
shot and all this stuff
obviously the [ __ ] a demon you
know what I mean like Michael's a demon
stop shooting him with a gun okay that's
not gonna work get some holy water dump
his ass in some cement and throw him in
the ocean but like this whole like
shooting him and all this III just don't
get why they keep doing that but this
one was cool they had some cool moments
where like she was stalking him and like
you know she fell and then like he's
looking around and then he looks where
she fell and she was gone and I was like
oh that's cool because that's what he
does right so Halloween was cool but the
nun was just I'm sorry that just I
cannot the nun was first of all the
trailer for the nun was the scariest
[ __ ] I'd seen in a long time the whole
theater was like what the nun came out
of nowhere and the whole thing was like
I swear to God that I was in a theater
whatever movie we were watching in the
holes place screamed and it was
frightening and I was the one going we
gonna be okay we gonna be okay y'all you
know it was like that's gay then I saw
the movie and I was like what like this
do got buried alive mad
and then he come afterwards he acting
like nothing happened like [ __ ]
if I wake up and I'm in a coffin and I
just managed to be got there believe you
me I'm out this [ __ ]
like we out okay and then she's walking
through this scary hallway she doesn't
seen this demon none like five times and
she acting like you know I'm just like
the nun was disappointing I like being
scared
I love being scared that's why I like
going to a movie you had that feeling I
love that that sensation but those those
two I wouldn't see the nun I don't
recommend it but Halloween I you know if
you still could see it watch it it's
just it's a fun homage to like all the
series it's been like seventeen movies I
think and it's pretty good so I've
watched that one yeah so how much when I
watch a movie
imma come on do a little brief like yo I
really enjoyed that and then also one of
my segments now I don't know anything
about pop culture I like to think I do
I'm not big on music I'm I never know
and this is the person that helps me
with all that stuff so welcoming to the
show this is my hot gay friend Cody
with hot pop culture gay news is it gay
it's pretty gay it's gonna be pretty gay
always I was going I was trying to make
a not gay list and then it just turned
out so you have some so Cody's here to
tell me about what's going on well it's
it's mostly music news if it's if it's
pop culture this week where they got the
voting stuff happening every all the
music people are talking about voting
okay you know so we have Jimbo I'm not
gonna answer that question because that
is my right to not answer that question
he's right just like it's my right to
vote or not to vote so um talk get to
the mic okay so um I see Cody is a very
gay all right
that's why I'm here okay so tell me what
we're doing so demi lovato made her
first appearance this week today
I'm making her statements about voting
or whatever and since when why is that a
big deal that Demi Lovato is that she
overdosed like two months ago she hasn't
been seen like at all since okay so Demi
Lovato overdosed and she hasn't been
seen in a while and this is her like
triumphant comeback - that's not a
triumphant comeback yet we're happy that
she's healthy her mom issued a press
release like a cup
weeks are about a month ago and we knew
she was okay she was alive and
everything I don't know what step she's
taking to get better or anything like
that if she's gonna be doing any music
or anything anytime soon but we do know
all the Disney stars that came out
around her time we're all falling apart
right now so good do you think it has to
do with Disney that people are falling
apart no I think it's the fame game I
don't think it's Disney particularly
being famous so young affects them
obviously but it's not Disney per se
it's like all of it seems to happen like
Britney it happened to Britney it
happens you know it happens to all of
them I guess really but like all it like
we've got now we've got ariana grande is
like mini Britney any day now like she's
just gonna fold you go shave her head we
wouldn't be surprised any day that she's
just wearing whoo you know a faux hawk
and she looks like Pete Wentz so is that
his name wait is that think she's dating
or maybe has to get from fall boy Pete
Davidson Pete Davis so you think she was
crazy so you have some cover federally
[ __ ] right there okay okay let's get
back to him back to it so wait ariana
grande's falling apart okay Demi Lovato
almost dies Selena Gomez checks yourself
into a mental hospital probably nervous
breakdown what's Justin Bieber gets
married to a girl that he barely knows
no he does no that's not true he's known
her for years
he's her for years but it seems to us
from talking to the mind don't point at
me just talking to the mic well it seems
to us that he doesn't know it's too
closer I don't know this is my first
time I hear so it's okay well you know
what this is what this is exactly the
sellers time we have a hot gay friend
segment
well the gays are gonna get out of here
just I can come on again so it wouldn't
be a bad thing okay so now we're talking
about Demi Lovato
yeah we were talking about Justin Bieber
oh we're back to book Justin Bieber
Justin Bieber to us it seems like he
doesn't know her because she has it
really been in the picture but this but
she actually has been in the picture
they've known each other for many years
since she would since they both were
very young I know that too but does it
not the way that they are now we didn't
go through a good according fruit period
with him in the public eye in the public
eye got right and then he's like married
to her in their super-religious and it's
weird and now he's saying that there's
part he's missing something in his life
so we're all like
and then you look like a Tweaker
homeless cracked-out person like two
weeks ago okay so anyways they're all
falling apart but onto happier cheerier
news the Spice Girls are gonna come back
the Spice Girls are back this is the
gang and this is big into gayness this
is this is big when I I think that all
the news is like it's like it's
generated based on my interest right
because how come on all the news sources
I got ten into Twitter it's all Spice
Girls okay it's like I said earlier on
CNN Spice Girls could be on there now
why are Spice Girls so important to you
well they were like the first music I
remember liking when I was little kid
okay all right so Spice Girls are big
the Spice Girls are back I did not know
that so thank you for that news yeah
well besides they all look oldest [ __ ]
and they don't know how to dress
themselves particularly flattering at
all yeah but they were famous like how
long ago was this so 21 years ago and
it's the same girls it's the same girls
so good for them good for except me the
one studious [ __ ] that we can't get to
come back to the table Victoria Beckham
is not gonna do the reunion
oh wait a minute Victoria Beckham was a
Spice Girl
you're a [ __ ] mess right now I I did
not know that Victoria Beckham was a
Spice Girl okay Victor so Posh Spice
she was Posh Spice did you hear posh
place but I know about posh my spices
like they starting to call Victoria posh
but the the Spice Girls kind of feel
like the dwarves you know you guys
sleeping
dumpy-dumpy I don't know which ones
dumpy don't be a spice girl the
alternate dumpy yeah it would be hot
missed four okay so night dwarf so this
so the Spice Girls are back and that's a
big deal for you it's not a big deal for
me it's a big deal for all the gays
everyone's super excited all UK is super
excited the world is excited okay now
the tour is limited to the United
Kingdom I guess unless it goes well then
they're gonna expand into a world tour
well I think they could are they okay
are they making new music see they're
super shady because Victoria was gonna
do it and then she backed out and then
Melanie is sporty spice backed out and
then now Victoria they announce that
they're doing it for sure contracts have
been signed
okay so they're coming and then posh is
like not doing it okay well that's big
okay that big news for some posh needs
it
sorry to interrupt you but
she needs it in the gays all hate her so
what does it feel like being the hated
Spice Girl
well that everyday hates her okay well I
leave that out to you people who hates
who H posh who was the spice crew you
hate the most
okay good all right what's next um well
since I can't I can't access my list
how about Ashlee Simpsons doing Carl's
jr. commercials now like yeah okay I
mean I don't see what's the problem with
that what why do you have a problem guys
there Ari indirect redoing it like Paris
like the only Carl's jr. commercial I
ever remember is Paris Hilton on a hood
of a car biting onto a Carl's jr. burger
right okay and that was like when Paris
Hilton Ashley Simpson famous at the same
time okay so now Ashley Simpson door
she's the face of it now she's like way
hot now like she's super duper hot she's
mom she's like she's a hot mom she is a
hot mom she's a MILF she is a total
she's like a XL milf okay I got you and
I'm not - check that out yo yeah and she
she's married to Donna Diana Ross's son
so she's got loads of money she's
looking to all the time and anyways but
she's like mom DUP for the commercial so
she's a rich hot mom that's you red
she's sexy and now she's got money okay
alright yeah she's like she's super
Hollywood and now she's like
representing that in the commercial I
think okay she's like Beverly Hills of
something oh no Carl's jr. we call she
her okay hot moms okay that's I think
that's all I got
is that all you got for this I do have
one more if you want to hear it listen
hey over here
okay so kanye west is going crazy as
always okay and we want to know when
it's gonna stop probably never you
saying the gays want to know or the gays
which are the gays really interested
this is only I'm only representing the
games no you're not just representing
the gays but I'm just curious because
you are the hot gay friend and we want
to know okay so go ahead well everyone's
kind of annoyed and insulted by kanye at
this point and even Kim fer kind of
co-signing all this [ __ ] but also
you saying that's my opinion
that's me are you saying that the gays
the Kim might lose the gays because of
Kanye's possible no I do think that's
awesome you know what we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna stay tuned with that
we're gonna keep looking at that in
future weeks and future episodes
we'll check back in with Cody is there
anything else you want - is that good
that's good you know so that's that's
well I don't know what you guys thought
about that segment but that is that was
uh you know news from my hot gay friend
skills so at the end Cody thanks for
coming on and we'll have Cody on in
future weeks to see what's going on in
the news but anyways that has been
riffing with Griffin episode three next
episode I think I'm gonna be talking
about some some communication I've been
reading some communication books and
I've been uh it's been life-changing and
I think I want to share that with you
guys but for now that's been whipping
with Griffin episode three thanks for
tuning in thank you very much good night
or good bye good bye is a good night who
knows you could be this Ennis to the
middle of day just how about signing off
Griffin with Griffin goodbye
[Music]